jean narac et parrainé cette année c'est
nox et rex isère applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
bb&t en forme alors obtenu pour alors
qu'est ce qu'il va se passer pour cette
dernière le groupe tout est à l'envers
donc c'est magnifique c'est que c'est
adam et non mais les mecs au le film est
le haut lieu les films hello c'est
patrick moquay merci en fait c'est vrai
que j'aimerais si vous aviez autant de
chansons préférées des animateurs
préférés
ouais c'est vrai c'est assez incroyable
et avant le prime c'est que des fois que
le dj ici mais des chansons que vous
n'aimez pas trop
ouais ça arrive quelques fois et le
problème c'est qu'en la personne qui
chante cette chanson bien quelques jours
après c'est un peu problématique
s'appelle hasard alors qu'est-ce qui les
a regardés rappelez-vous d'hazard mais
heureusement ils s'adorent asa
heureusement je vous remets le laurier
de l'animateur qui est grande qualité de
changer très vite d'avis quelques
semaines notre dj a émis une chanson de
hasard en retour de publicité est
manifestement vous notifier par
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça crie ça bizarre et pourtant quelques
jours plus tard quand hazard est venu
jouer son titre elle avait complètement
changé d'avis
[Applaudissements]
cette nuit
c'est pas pour ça que j'ai fait ça c'est
pas bon ça parce que c'est un mec génial
et qui cartonne mais bien sûr il ne
fallait pas envie d'entendre ça à ce
moment là des paroles françaises
vous nous prenez vraiment et lui me
connais moi si je le connais très bien
alors attention j'ai organisé un petit
sondage auprès des fans de ma chronique
et non plus huit personnes qui m'ont
aidé
9 je leur ai demandé quels étaient leurs
séquences préférées des lauriers et bien
c'est le zumba back where our au 1 c'est
quand on zoome sur votre visage série
100 des moments où c'est un peu choqué
ou étonné voici donc la crème de la
crème des zooms baba souvenez vous que
lorsque je vous avais suggéré le
propager le chocolat gueye dans toutes
les émissions de ces villes avaient la
rédac la réaction la plus mythique de la
saison cholet
ça c'est une preuve d'amour j'espère que
demain durant le chocolat gueddar
williams à midi
on va dans ton post le petit charlie a
eu la gentillesse de nous offrir un
chocolat mais quand vous alliez croquer
dedans c'était la même chose que dans le
père noël est une ordure ce n'est pas
très bon et du premier trimestre de
l'année 2010 9 sél et philosophe et puis
le zumba préféré de tout le monde c'est
quand vous étiez rendu compte que kerry
était en fait une mathématicienne averti
c'est très vaste et où ça touche pas à
mon poste on a la chance d'avoir de
grands orateurs
c'est jean-michel qui bafouille benjamin
castaldi qui marmonne maxime kenny qui
invente des mots on comprend rien en
fait
mais y'en a un autre ici qui est un
langage bien particulier qui nécessite
parfois quelques visionnage c'est vous
si je vous assure oui mais je suis fier
de vous remettre le laurier de celui qui
va jouer dans la suite du film de franck
gastambide la caillera la semaine
dernière isabelle morini-bosc vous a
fait une demande officielle syrie déjà
demande à cindy ça veut dire quoi darron
ça veut dire quoi alors je sais pas
pourquoi je veux qu'on traduise puisque
on comprend très bien quand vous parlez
de suture mais la nouvelle étude comment
je vais faire en ce moment ils sont
noirs et ses drames de maximy contre
l'as dit papa me prévenez machine tu n
bel air avec le cdt l'école c'est marine
qui rentre
la mer la map est en coton alors j'ai
voulu vérifier je vais diffuser une
nouveau phrase on va voir si la belle
comprend ce que vous dites
[Musique]
alors on mène voir vous aviez un langage
qui n'appartenait qu'à vous et il ya
également deux phrases que vous dites
souvent la première s'est désolé mais
finalement en aura pas d'augmentation la
première vous aurez compris la deuxième
on va la découvrir tout de suite c'est
en quatre mots je vous remets de
lauriers du gars il nous le dit cyril
une fois ce que vous répétez tout le
temps redit jeudi qu'il avait ravi la
mer voilà je vous dis je vous dis je
vous dis je vous le dis donc je vous le
dis oui je vous le dis en moyenne ou
fait 15 je vous le dis par émission soit
240 je vous le dis par mois pas vous
donc voilà je vous dis ollier vous dis
déjà dit la région d'yvonand je dis ça
nous fait donc 2160 je vous le dis par
saison ce qui signifie que depuis le
début de tpm pays lenovo vous avez
répété 10915 moi je le dis oui oui oui
parce est envoyée
beaucoup
jusqu'à maintenant surtout de savoir qui
sera élu le dernier tard baba est
reparti avec ce magnifique trophée le
trophée tout l'été pour le ramener à
l'avant scène avec ma très bien voilà
qu'une boule et ben parce que il
malheureusement il en a perdu non